[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte euch heute ihm einen
kick basics die garage vorstellen eine
garage ist die verbindung aus schokolade
und sahne also eine art schokoladencreme
und zwar mache ich die auf zwei
verschiedene arten einmal die canucks
zum gefühl und einmal die canucks zum
bestreichen und die beiden unterscheiden
sich letztendlich in der konsistenz denn
die gagen bestreichen führt zum beispiel
motiv torten ist etwas fester weil ich
da einen festen untergrund brauche wenn
ich die torte später mit von dong also
mit zucker teig überziehen möchte und
die garage zum befüllen ist etwas
weicher man schlägt er auch auf das ist
dann wie so eine art schokoladen sahne
wie musste zum beispiel aus einer
schokoladen torte kennt und ich zeige
euch jetzt erstmal die
mengenverhältnisse für die garage zum
befüllen
denn die verändern sich je nach
schokoladensorten und wenn ich jetzt
eine garage machen möchte zum befüllen
mit zum beispiel zartbitter schokolade
braucht ihr diese zutaten und zwar ist
da das verhältnis auf 300 gramm sahne
gebe ich 200 gramm zucker schokolade bei
der vollmilch schokolade ist es anders
da nämlich 200 gramm sahne und 200 gramm
vollmilchschokolade und bei der weißen
schokolade nämlich 200 gramm sahne und
300 gramm weiße schokolade und wenn ich
jetzt aber dieser garage benutzen möchte
um meine motiv torten damit
einzustreichen muss sich das verhältnis
wieder anpassen da die ja fester sein
muss und da nehme ich für die tat bitter
ghanas auf 200 gramm sahne 400 gramm
sagt bitterschokolade auf 200 gramm
sahne 500 gramm vollmilchschokolade und
bei der weißen ganache auf 200 gramm
sahne 600 gramm weiße schokolade und
wenn ihr jetzt zb auch schokoladen mit
anderen geschmacksrichtungen habt wie zb
einem acker schokolade dann nehmt ihr da
genau das verhältnis wie bei der
vollmilch kann also mit der
vollmilchschokolade ihr könnte auch noch
für familien schokolade nehmen oder eine
mit einer himba füllung also da können
wir alles mögliche nehmen auf jeden fall
das verhältnis von der volme ghanas
benutzen
und ich würde sagen ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal an haben
von der stadt peter gagelmann sie
herstellt und sagt euch später was die
alternative wäre zuerst gebt ihr jetzt
die sahne in einen topf und die muss
dann kurz aufgekocht werden
[Musik]
und wenn sie dann einmal aufgekocht ist
macht ihr den herd aus und jetzt gebe
ich die schokolade in kleinen stückchen
mit rein
und jetzt muss ich mit einem schneebesen
oder mit einem kochlöffel oder mit einem
teig scheibe einfach hören bis sich die
schokolade aufgelöst hat und ich keine
klümpchen mehr mit drin haben und die
alternative zur garage wäre beim motiv
torten zb als untergrund eine
buttercreme die könnt ihr auch benutzen
aber keine deutsche buttercreme also mit
pudding und butter denn der zu viel
feuchtigkeit würde denn von dort
aufweichen
deswegen braucht ihr dann eine
amerikanische buttercreme die eben nur
auf fett und zucker basis ist und das
ist mir meistens einfach zu süß deswegen
nehme ich am liebsten die ghana schals
und als untergrund für die motiv torten
[Musik]
die ghana schwertern umgefüllt und muss
dann erstmal abkühlen
und wenn ich jetzt die feste geschmack
zum bestreichen von torten lasse ich sie
einfach bei zimmertemperatur abkühlen am
besten über nacht da stelle ich sie dann
zum beispiel einen kühlen raum und da
kann sie einfach fest werden und sie
muss dann so fest werden dass sie
streichfähig ist und ich dann damit eine
torte gut bestreichen kann wenn ihr
jetzt zu warme temperaturen habt in der
küche können das auch ganz kurz in den
kühlschrank stellen vor der verwendung
aber im normalfall wird sie dann eben zu
kalt ich zeige euch jetzt aber gleich
noch die alternative und zwar wenn ich
die garage zum befüllen habe möchte ich
sie ja auch schön luftig aufschlagen das
ist eine ganz normale schokoladen sahne
und ich habe ich einmal das zweite
beispiel das ist auch eine zeit mit der
gage aber eben zum befüllen und man
sieht eben auch schon am farb
unterschied hier ist weniger schokolade
mit drin
deswegen ist sie heller und die wird im
kühlschrank gelagert denn wenn ich die
aufschlagen möchte muss er ganz kalt
sein so wie eben sahne auch kalt sein
muss beim aufschlagen
auf jeden fall war das jetzt so mein
grundrezept die garage summen
bestreichen ist wenn ihr sie nicht auf
schlag im kühlschrank haltbar etwas drei
wochen ihr könnt reste auch ganz gut
einfrieren und bei bedarf wieder
aufbauen und ich hoffe dass euch dieses
rezept weiter geholfen habt und er keine
frage mehr haft falls ihr doch noch
fragen habt stellt sie einfach bei mir
die kommentare ich werde euch
beantworten und die weiteren infos gibts
dann einfach auf meinem blog this blog
de
[Musik]